Eric is with us in New Jersey higher I
tell you hi Davis I know not to speak to
you how are you better than I deserve
sir now how can I help
yes sir okay I'm on baby step two I'm
married with two beautiful daughters and
I have a question for you
my wife she believes mostly on
everything I just said
what does Anita she works on a bank so
she sell those products those credit
cards loans she actually got a training
two days ago about hillocks and
mortgages and stuff like that and she
also get complex compensated which
itself this type of product so I'm
trying to pull her away from that word
but at the place she works is like it's
like a fight that I'm constantly leaving
so she actually believed in that but at
the same time she's trying to follow the
plan in order to work together with me
and I need a wise advice herb you know
it's very difficult to be good at
something that you don't believe all
right that's coming home and working
beside you and saying okay we're going
to be good at getting out of debt when I
think debt is awesome if you think debt
is awesome you're not gonna be good at
getting out of debt
on the other hand if you're trying to
get out of debt at home then you're not
gonna be good at selling debt at work
right right right now the last thing she
agreed on the plan she was a seven-month
arguing fight I put in some videos of
you I was able to convince her to for
her to allow me to pay her credit card
so we can put everything together we
have combined finances and only that we
have so far is our car and she's pretty
much following every advice I'm giving
her but a little bit concerned
watching what she's doing that work and
what we're doing at home well it's just
a con it's a conflicted thing I mean
that's that's reasonable it's it's it's
hard to do that and so I understand to
understand what she's facing what does
she make a year he's making 3,100
I'm sorry $31,000 okay and how long has
she been at the bank this year will be
her ten years of experience in banking
right and what do you make I make in
46,000 right now well I mean what we
might do is start setting a goal that
allows her to change careers and maybe
do something that she likes better she
says she likes real estate she likes
real estate she says that but no no
that's what so ever and she is already
38 years old well that's okay so why
don't why don't we start working towards
getting your real estate license while
she stays at the bank she can do real
estate part-time yeah and learn about it
and get going get her career moving
because if she started making as much
money doing real estate on the side and
she was at the bank she'd quit the bank
right yeah definitely I good and she's
we don't know what she loves
right right she's being very awful all
these years because that's the only job
opportunity she follow and there's lots
of job opportunities and one of them is
real estate I would pursue some real
estate doesn't she does quit today but
the court making job today but but you
know hey she's 38 by the time she's 42 I
want to be in a real estate agent yeah
we're gonna be debt-free in a year and a
half mm-hmm so I guess and we doing
pretty good but honest way the answer is
the answer to question how do you get
your wife on board is or how do i how
does my wife deal with this conflict of
selling debt at work but getting out of
that at home is letter help her
gradually step by step step into her
dream
being a real estate agent you be a good
husband serve her help her live her
dream and when you do that it's gonna
solve all of this stuff but it's gonna
take a little bit of time it's not gonna
be quick it might take two years she's
gonna stay in the banking job for next
couple of years probably but she gets
her license she's just some knowledge as
you said starts to learn about the
business makes a couple sales working on
the weekends and evenings when she's not
at the bank which is by the way when
most people look at houses anyway and it
gets a couple transactions under her
belt you guys are out of debt you start
to build up some savings you feel more
comfortable with her because she's
making money in real estate but maybe
not quite making as much as the bank
then she could quit the bank and make
the transition and I think you help her
live her dream sounds to me like thanks
for the call